so i have six different fractions
written out here what i want you to do
is pause this video right now and try to
rewrite each of these fractions as a
decimal
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
so let's go through each of these
so we know
that when we say 34 10 or 34 over 10
that this could be interpreted literally
as 34
34 divided
by 10. and so if you start with 34 let
me put a little decimal right over here
to be clear that there is an implied
decimal there so we could just keep
adding zeros if we want so when we
divide by 10 we're going to move the
decimal one space over to the left and
you should always do a reality check if
you forget hey do i move it over to the
left or do it or do i do it over to the
right you should do a reality check look
if i'm dividing by 10 should i get a
smaller value or a larger value well
clearly if you're dividing it into 10
groups you should get a smaller value so
when you take your decimal place to the
left you're going to get a smaller value
34 is going to become 34 is going to
become
3.4 and that makes complete sense if you
were to multiply 3.4 by 10 you would
move the decimal to the right and you
would get to 34.
let's think about this one so this one
right over here is 3.4
let's think about seven tenths so the
exact same idea the exact same idea this
is equal to this is equal to 7 divided
by 10.
7 divided by 10. this fraction
i guess horizontal line symbol thing
could literally be viewed as divided by
this could be read as 7 divided by 10.
so when you divide by 10 you move the
decimal one space over one space over to
the left so we're going to get to .7 and
just to be clear we could write this as
0.7 it's sometimes dangerous to just
write the decimal without the 0 out
front so 7 10 or 7 divided by 10 could
be rewritten as 0.7
now let's try 53
hundredths
well
we'll start with our 53 once again this
could be interpreted as 53 divided by
divided by 100 so there's an implied
decimal point right over here now if
we're dividing by 100 that's dividing by
10
and then dividing by 10 again this is
dividing by 10 times 10 so we're going
to divide by 10
and then we're going to divide by 100 so
the decimal is going to land right over
there so that's going to get us to 0.53
now let's tackle 2 divided by 100.
so let's just this once again
this could be rewritten as 2 divided by
100 2 hundredths is the same thing as 2
divided by 100. if we start with the 2
put our decimal point right there so
we're going to divide by 10 and we're
going to do that twice so we're going to
divide by 10 once that would be
two-tenths that puts our decimal there
but we have to divide by 10 again you
might say hey look there's nothing here
well you could just throw a zero on here
just so that you do have something there
and then you have moved your decimal
over by oh to the left twice and
remember every time you're doing it
you're dividing by 10. you're dividing
by 10 then you're dividing by 10 again
dividing by 10 two times that's the same
thing as dividing by a hundred because
ten times ten is a hundred so this is
going to be
this is going to be zero
zero point zero two and we've already
seen that if you were to try to read
this this two is in the hundredths place
so you would literally read this as two
hundredths and we see that right over
here we've literally represented it as
two hundredths right over there
two hundredths
so now we have one thousand ninety eight
divided by a hundred well same drill
or one thousand ninety-eight hundredths
i could say that's the same thing as
1098 divided by a hundred so we could
start with one thousand ninety-eight
the decimal is implicitly right over
here but we need to move it two spaces
to the left one two because we're
dividing by a hundred
that gets us to ten
point
nine eight and always do a reality check
look it makes sense we got to a
significantly smaller value when we
divided by a hundred
let to divide
967 by a thousand
well 9967
decimal point implicitly there
now a thousand is 10 times 10 times 10.
so if you're dividing by a thousand
that's dividing by 10 three times so we
divide by 10 once divide by 10 twice
divide by 10 three times we get to 9.967
so another way of writing
nine hundred 9960
thousandths is well that's just going to
be nine point nine hundred and
sixty-seven or i can literally read it
as nine and
nine hundred and sixty-seven thousandths
and that also makes sense i mean you
could break this up into 9000 plus 967
and so 9 000 thousandths is going to be
9
and then you're going to be left with
the 967 thousandths